hi guys I'm not see I'm the beauty
editor here at Glamour UK and we're here
with the amazing Vlada lip
editor-in-chief of Smashbox cosmetics
and she is going to teach us how to do
this incredible lip and rose gold makeup
look so obviously you've got your new
petal metal collection
yes Smashbox and this is one of the
staple Smashbox products it's very very
subtle it just gives you that super
super beautiful radiant glow so what are
we thinking well you have this lovely
dress I really love this color it's very
I didn't you know it just came to me not
really
yes it's very happy so I really love
monochromatic looks so I feel like maybe
let's do something that kind of matches
your dress a little bit but with a lot
of spin
I really like this shade I feel like
rose gold it's a new peach it was a real
peach Raymond yeah I just let me upgrade
this is like the fancy peach you can
either use your finger to apply the
metallic shadows because they're so
pigmented they will grab onto your lid
beautifully or you can use a brush too I
want to add a little bit of depth just
above our main color this palette I
think it's gonna change your life
because it's just it's really it's so
easy to work with it it's insane using
the same shade I'm gonna put just a tiny
bit on your lower eyelash and what it
does it just it opens the eye a little
more this is a shade that you can use
for contouring as well so do your face
yeah it's just like a small that seems
like your path I like to me I think
people have already confused I think
they have to use really dark colors oh
yeah don't get me started on this also
it's gonna make your eye eyes look a
little more awake and open like you just
had eight hours of sleep yes please
which is such a great shade for you I
love it can't stop smiling
don't stop now this is actually great I
love to apply highlighter on the apples
of the cheeks too so when you smile it
gives you that kind of yeah yeah yeah
hello you want to touch all of the high
points of your face with the highlighter
and just kind of it brings it forward so
I'm thinking for your dress I feel like
this is gonna be just perfect and this
is another Smashbox a lipstick and tar
pit it's just true black oh wow
yeah something I don't think I've ever
had black lips before really whoa oh I'm
so honored I love black lipstick I think
it's just so rocking and empowering yeah
it's just a edgy so I'm actually gonna
start with Desert Rose and then I will
detail with the black lipstick okay so
that's kind of a technique that I like
to use if I want to do a pattern on the
lips I really like to use like fabric
patterns or architecture and just like
things that you would normally not think
of as makeup ideas but then you
transform them into little bars let's
imagine - oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna just
gently dab on top of the cheek I'd like
to highlight before and that just gives
just an extra pop of glow can I look now
I'm happy yes yes oh wow
that is cool that's Coachella cool yes
Shradha thank you so much thank you your
beard oh my gosh I hope you enjoyed this
amazing rose gold tutorial with the
wonderful flutter comment below let us
know what you think and if you want more
videos like this don't forget to
subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube
channel
[Music]